da trifft sich also ein großteil der
westlichen welt aber auch viele andere
länder und wollen ja so nirgendwo
signalisieren jetzt müssen wir uns
zusammenraufen und jetzt müssen wir
anfangen mehr für das klima zu tun
wirklich dafür zu kämpfen es ist noch
ein bisschen schwierig wenn die alle mit
ihren privatjets kommen und auch die
ganzen moralaposteln die ceos die
sogenannten grünen cios wie jeff bezos
der amazon gründer zum beispiel der
wirklich seit jahren auch für
klimaschutz predigt auch wenn der mit
seinem privatjet kommt und woher kommt
er von einer privaten geburtstagsparty
von bill gates die in der nähe der
türkischen küste auf einer mega yacht
stattfand ja also eine megajacht auf der
die gäste auch natürlich per helikopter
eingeflogen wurden anders kann man als
klimaretter offenbar nicht feiern also
wenn man von diesem gipfel irgendwie ein
zeichen ausgehen soll für die normalen
menschen dass die sich zusammenreißen
sollen dass sie sich vielleicht weniger
ins ausland weniger in den urlaub
fliegen sollen weniger auto fahren
sollen da kann man sich noch fragen also
wollten wir uns eigentlich veralbern der
soldaten glauben